Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, this is my new favorite caller.
This is a delightful lady from Texas
who is very politely correcting me on
my pronunciation of something. I can't think
of a more delightful recent caller than this.
Check it out.
Speaker 2:
Hi, David. I just wanted to let you know.
Speaker 1: That, by the way, the voice
cracking I know is even more delightful.
Let's. Let's listen to it one more time.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I just wanted
to let you know that here in Texas,
we don't say you have all day. We say you valley.
It reminds me of you, pal. Me? You know it rhymes
you valley, please. Correct. I know you're
not from Texas, but that's the way it's
pronounced here. You Valley. Thank you. Bye.
Speaker 1: This is the best caller. Now,
I'm going to admit to you what's going on with
my pronunciation of that town in Texas. As many
of you know, I'm from Argentina. Okay. When I look
at that word, Uvalde. To me, it's in Spanish and
it's oubaali. That's the that's the that's the
pronunciation. Any time I just pronounce a word
the way it should be pronounced in Spanish like
oubaali. People write in and they go, David, oh,
my God, you're doing that pretentious, pompous
thing where it's sort of like when someone will
very jarringly interrupt what they're saying to
say Gonzalez instead of Gonzalez. And it's jarring
and it's pretentious and it's pompous. Don't do
that. And the problem with me not just pronouncing
it the way it is, which is Oubaali, is I don't
actually know which wrong pronunciation should
I use? Uvalde de Uvalde de they're all wrong guys,
right? I mean, it's just I need to pick the right,
incorrect American Anglicized pronunciation
of what we all would know as wilder. Wilder
in the state of Texas. All right, so I apologize.
I throw myself at your mercy. But that is that's
my new favorite caller on the bonus show today.
The Wilder Police and the Wilder School District
are no longer cooperating with the Texas
investigation into the shooting last week
in Uvalde. We're going to talk about what's
going on building on the story at the top of
the podcast today. The Supreme Court has blocked
a new Texas social media law from taking effect.
What's in the law? And why is it being
blocked? We will tell you. And lastly,
there are more and more Democrats opting to vote
in Republican primaries merely to vote against
Donald Trump's nominee. We're going to talk
about whether this is a good idea, a risky idea,
etc.. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, easy. Alex, I invite you
not not to buy any kind of weird supplements, but
just to sign up at join pacman dot com, become a
member. You can use the coupon code big
voting 22 to save bigly and we will see
you on today's bonus show. Or if you're not
a member. I will see you back here tomorrow.